[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
heute gibt es mal ein spontanes
kochrezept denn ich habe jetzt gerade
eine torte zubereitet und die torte
steht im kühlschrank für zwei stunden
und jetzt ist bei unserer mittagszeit
alle kriegen etwas hunger und deswegen
wird jetzt gekocht war ein pastagericht
und es gehört immer saumäßig schnell und
es ist ein
board to board ok und erklärt auch
gleich warum ihr könnt aber auch als
antwort zur verein ist cool ich halt
konsole drin ich glaube den geschmack
von consolar kommt er spät war ich
glaube ganz ganz jungen jahren machen
wir nicht so ich glaube auch weil früher
macht denn auch nicht und dann
irgendwann habe ich mich mal dran
probiert weil dort so unserem
blauschimmelkäse als kind findet unseres
ekelhaft ja ich würde nämlich sagen ich
starte direkt das rezept dauert nicht
länger als 20 minuten und ich zeige euch
gleich mal kurz die zutaten und sagt
auch gleich was dazu dafür nehme ich
eine knoblauchzehe eine zwiebel oder
eine charlotte etwas butter und mehl für
die mehlschwitze gemüsebrühe das ist
jetzt meine selbstgemachte 300
milliliter davon 200 milliliter milch
dann habe ich hier 200 gramm käse 50
km/h sahen hier mein gemüse nämlich
tiefkühl erbsen 150 gramm einen großen
brokkoli sind etwa 500 gramm und wenn
ihr möchtet könnt ihr gerne pushing
hinzufügen und dann einfach nudeln eurer
wahl dazu geben und ich hab jetzt hier
eigentlich und ich weiß nicht wie du
dazu steht ich weiß noch wie gestern
abend über pasta gerichte gesprochen und
er hat immer klappt macht doch mal
wieder ein paar vor gericht so schnell
durch die pfanne 10 und ich weiß welches
bild einem kopf hat er ein bild im kopf
da ist so eine schöne soße und die
zitate teller nudeln und da hab ich mir
überlegt die tagliatelle oder nämlich
andere nudeln und dann habe ich hier die
orte entdeckt von und die haben wir noch
aus österreich von spa aber auch schon
gegeben
das war bei uns in der weihnachts box
drin dass man geschenk von intersport
okay und ich hatte noch nie die orte und
die sind sie sehen einfach so gut aus
doch dieser kann nur in eurer wahl
wiederholt am nächsten und den den den
käse auch aus wie soll ich sein ersetzen
in gouda zum beispiel ja ich dachte mein
papa winter vorbei vorbei also dann
fangen wir mit dem kochen im kopf nicht
mehr helfen ja komm ich hätte kurz jetzt
geht es schnell da
komm ich hab dir ein bisschen so ok
ansteht zwiebel schälen und schneiden
und die knoblauchzehe
habe ich habe extra dorthin helfen da
noch genau ich erkläre so lange ihr
könnt nämlich jetzt entweder das ganze
als rammbock zu bereiten da würde ich es
einfach so nach in soße zubereiten und
mehr flüssigkeit benutzen und das ganze
drin ich weiß aber auch immer dass meine
italienischen zuschauer sie kriegen
jedes mal an herzinfarkt wenn ich an
bord rudel gerichte machen weil sie
sagen die nudel müssen schwimmen
deswegen werde ich sie heute art
zubereitet ich hätte schon mal das
wasser auf die firma spontan dass du mit
mir haben wir mit dir los am
hochzeitstag oder war nicht einfach nur
wo
werde ich jetzt echt anwendungen und ok
wer will ihnen sagen dass ich alleine
stemmen kann es macht spaß und
[Musik]
ich bin ich mache das zur gewohnheit
dass seine zeit zusammen verbringen
möglich ist wollen wir nicht
okay jetzt gebe ich schon mal die butter
und das melden die pfanne und kann das
ganze an rüsten
[Musik]
so schön die mehlschwitze ja ich sehr
lecker duftet
ja ja alles okay
ja und jetzt die zwiebeln die zwiebel
und knoblauch würzen dazu schon anbraten
ja das übrigens meine gemüsebrühe die
ich immer selber zubereiten habe ich
immer gläser im kühlschrank wo ich
einfach gemüsereste und salz haben da
könnt ihr wirklich jedes gemüse können
so alle zwei wochen zum beispiel eure
gemüsereste einfach vermissen wir das
salz vermischen und da gibt es auch
schon rezept auf einem kanal das war
denke ich ganz gerne also meine frau tot
wie man alles ein machen ich glaube auch
dass sie irgendwann mal mich ein macht
oder irgend jemand von uns hinein machen
als an machen
[Musik]
kannst du schon mal die
den brokkoli vielleicht auch schneidend
ja und zwar aber denkmal und darf das
auch erst im märz und da hätte ich jetzt
ganz gerne dass diese kleinen röschen
was so einzelne kleine bäumchen
ich liebe brokkoli über alles deswegen
kenne mich da aus
[Musik]
das nudelwasser kocht jetzt auch und
schreibt wirklich ordentlich salz
zugeben ich mag ich gar keine nudeln die
nicht genug salz haben
die nudelsorten braucht zwölf minuten
das heißt sie kann ich schon mal rein
stimmlich richtig fürs fest sein ich
mache ja nicht so lässig wie deine
mutter macht sie muss so so so nochmal
getötet tschuldigung wir reden hier
nicht über die kochkünste meine order
deiner mutter kind
los gehts hier das ganze mit der brühe
aufgießen und
murat kannst du mir vielleicht die milch
noch dazu geben ja ich könnte mich ja
auch hab mich nehmen kann man hier als
möglich
und statt butter olivenöl genau und
starts käse ersatz die kirmes
organisiert ja aber nicht dass es vorher
aber ich sag es nur damit mich gefragt
wer tatsächlich muss ich echt sagen dass
veganer parmesan sehr lecker schon mal
den mit haferflocken macht und cashew
das ist total lecker ich habe das immer
im kopf gemacht okay weil schwarzer mal
kannst es erzählt klein würfeln
schön mit kleinen juwel ist das hier
einfach kurz aufkochen dem karton
schüler ein messer
wenn dann hier die soße kocht könnt ihr
schon mal die würfel tieren dazu geben
bei denen die so ins netz so bissfest
bleiben
sonst kann man die nicht so gut zu
erkennen
ok dann kann ich noch den puten schinken
klein schneiden und
die diesen strom der ist ein bisschen
härter als der poco die selbst den lasse
ich nicht so 23 minuten köcheln und den
brokkoli gebe ich dann ja
wir können auch schon mal
den käse dazu geben einmal parmesan und
eben auch den controller
den könnte nämlich einfach weil er schon
so weit ist somit den händen bisschen
dazu rücken
so sieht echt schon super mag schon
mittags als einkäufer vielleicht reihe
und muss man nur noch salz bild also
lasst lieber erstmal pfeffer
ich meine du hast
jetzt weiß ich warum nicht so ob david
zu kochen reicht ist oder
ich weiß schon beleidigt dinge
komprimieren kann ich lasse
ich kann das alleine war
ich weiß aber ich bin eine frau wir aber
[Musik]
ich kann es doch
doch ein bisschen salz hat recht
wenn ich es ist geschmackvoll aber das
salz
nicht gedacht muss ja nicht sein ok dann
können wir jetzt den brokkoli und
entboten schenken dazugeben und falls es
vegetarisch zubereiten wollte einfach
weglassen
boccoli dazu
die erbsen und
gerne auch den chef
[Musik]
da gebe ich jetzt ein deckel drauf damit
der brokkoli noch zeit zum durchgang
kennen wir sollten das öfter machen nein
findet ihr nicht auch nur kurz 18 uhr 30
sekunden also können wir auch
[Musik]
also ich nehme jetzt noch ein bisschen
nudelwasser
und streckt die soße okay
und dann kann ich nämlich die nudeln
abgießen
dazu nicht mehr strecken es reicht schon
ja
ich würde sie müssen ja
das kann man sagen man kann jetzt auch
lachs reinmachen lag zwischen richtig
cool
[Musik]
bis zu
280 komme gerade bei susi und strolch
und ich gemacht mein gott was gehen
wenn wir gerade mal acht jahre alt war
schon
sauer sie schnell ich bin glaube ich ist
ein bisschen chlorophyll genau
vielleicht sind sie ja
erstmal unser gericht probieren
[Musik]
voßkuhle ist noch dass der brokkoli
bissfest ist und die die erbsen auch und
die amedia mini lässt zu lange macht man
dann schmeckt wirklich sowieso so ein
kartenhaus krankenhaus genommen wobei
kein held an die krankenhäuser
lekker
mobils gericht gerne aus wie gesagt ein
schönes 20 minuten gericht und gerne
deftige mir in die kommentare schreiben
ob morath wieder öfter mit kochen hat
ist unser erstes gemeinsames koch video
in zehn jahren nur noch nicht viel
gemacht nicht viele sachen gekauft
es gibt menschen die behaupten ich werde
ich war nur geld kostet dies geht aus
einer echten familie
und kinder sind aufwand
also fragen sie mich auch schon einen
echten kinder ja die katzen
[Musik]